[Music]
uh
hello and welcome to i'd like to know my
name is c.a murray and i'm in the
company of our president and founder
pastor stephen warr pastor as always
good to be with you it's good to work
with you too ca i'm sorry that you go to
panama now and then we miss you but i'm
glad to work with you it's good to be
missed
perhaps you've heard the the expression
kid in a candy shop
uh which means that uh you're going
through an experience that you really
really love well this is our pastor our
kid in the candy shop amen for the
program that's right we really like this
program for a number of reasons one we
like to answer your questions we like to
hear from you we'd like to know what's
on your mind those things that are of
interest to you those things that may be
troubling you uh those questions that
you have from the word of god and two
we just like studying the word of god
and we like studying the word of god
together and so this program gives us an
opportunity to do precisely that so it's
it's a fun program for us and we hope it
is a blessing to you as together we
search the word of god and find answers
from the word of god and we of course
make you this promise that the answers
that we give will always be from the
word of god if there's an answer to be
found in the word of god we will find it
or find someone who knows the answer uh
but we're going to bring everything from
the word of god you don't need to hear
our opinions a little too late in
earth's history for the opinions of man
we want to hear a word from the lord and
that is what we promise to give you amen
should you want to get in on the fun
should you want to be part of this
program you can send your questions into
tv
at some tv dot o r g that is tv
at some tv dot o r g and we will get to
them
if you do not hear them right away be
patient with us please because the list
is long and growing pastor amen we're
getting to as fast as we can but we
don't want to rush through the questions
we want to take each time uh take
definite time with each answer so that
we answer your questions thoroughly
sometimes we get to two or three
questions a day sometimes four uh
sometimes only one or two but we want to
answer the questions thoroughly so be
patient with us please we'll get to them
uh sooner or later and we praise the
lord for that pastor if you would um
have prayer for us we want to begin
let's do yeah
father in heaven we come before your
awesome throne in the powerful name of
jesus
recognizing that our wisdom is so
limited
you are infinite
you know everything
and all the answers to our questions are
found in your holy word
therefore as we open your holy word
we ask that your holy spirit will be
with us to open our minds and hearts
give us understanding
help us to answer the questions in
harmony with your word and with the
spirit of prophecy
and we ask that this program will be a
blessing to those who are watching in
jesus name we pray amen amen and amen
all right our initial question actually
was addressed to pastor miranda uh but
uh we're going to take it in his absence
and wrestle with it just a little bit it
is from yaffet t
does not spell out the last name but uh
yafet here's your question
i was wondering if there's a way to get
a question answered for me regarding
grounds for divorce
there are many men who struggle with
porn addiction and some wives consider
this as fornication
a reason for divorce
is this biblically sound
also does paul seem to say in first
corinthians 7 15 that the believing
spouse is freed from the marriage bond
if the unbelieving spouse abandons
abandons them
i am very curious what pastor boar's
response to these things is please and
thank you so perhaps
we do well to read first corinthians 7
so that we're all on the same page as to
what
the speaker is talking about and the
question that he is addressing
so first corinthians chapter 7
i am there and we are
zeroing in on verse 15.
pastor with your permission i will read
it go ahead but if the unbeliever
departs
let him depart a brother or sister is
not under bondage in such cases but god
has called us to peace
so we've got
a couple of issues to deal with um
one is this idea of a
unbelieving spouse and then another is
the idea of pornography
as a grounds for divorce
um
a couple of things i want to i want to
say and then i want to put it in your
very capable hand since the question was
addressed to you
as respects part a of his question
that is to deal with with pornography
uh i want to pull out one text from the
old testament and one text from the new
psalms chapter 101 verse 3
i will set no wicked thing before my
eyes
that to me is a
a dictum by which all christians should
should live their lives
there are many things that are on the
television set that we
don't bless us don't edify us
uh and pornography which you have to go
to specific sites to to see
uh certainly should not be uh consumed
by the christian there is a a mental
thing that goes on when you're looking
at pornography
that certainly is not sanctified by god
and does not help the the marriage vows
does not help
now the fact that you're not in
a situation with an exact person but
you're fantasizing about a situation by
what is going on on the screen in front
of you
uh
to me breaks the marriage vows pastor it
it it it does you promise to love honor
and obey one woman one man uh now you
are having mental exercises
by what you're watching with someone
else
which is to my thinking
a form of of adultery because your your
lusts your loyalties your mindset is
with someone else who is not your wife
and uh that is forbidden in the bible
then you had a new testament texas i did
you're probably thinking about the same
one i am philippians no okay
no our minds are not on the same track
right now but i'm sure yours is a good
one yeah um
philippians chapter 4 verse 8
i'll read just the the
the end of it because the text says if
there be any virtue
and if there be any praise
think on these things right
contrasting if there is no virtue if
there's no praise if it does not build
up if it does not edify it does not draw
to the lord then you ought not think on
those things for me i i look at my life
at this point
this way
i'm in the last
third of my of my time here on planet
earth i have x number of hours to do
what god wants me to do
i don't want to waste any of that time
putting before my mind feeding my mind
with putting before my eyes those things
which will pull me away from god those
things that have no virtues have no
praise which do not uplift me which do
not draw me closer to god there are
there are x number of hours left in my
life
i want to spend as many of those hours
doing what i can to build up the kingdom
of god and in getting myself ready so
that means there are certain things that
may not be wrong
per se
but i don't have time for them
you know i don't want to waste time
there are other things that are just
wrong and i don't want to be caught
doing those things because it takes away
from the time that i have yeah
very good thoughts
uh the text that i uh think of when it
comes to the issue of pornography
uh is matthew chapter 7 27 and uh
matthew chapter 5 27-28
here jesus said you have heard that it
was said to those of old
you shall not commit adultery
so the command is explicit right yes
first shall not commit adultery which
means that if you're married and you lie
with another woman
you're committing adultery
uh and that says in the following verse
here jesus is speaking but i say to you
that whoever looks at a woman
who looks at a woman
would that include
pornography
being forbidden i believe so i do agree
but i say to you that whoever looks at a
woman to lust for her has already
committed adultery with her
in his heart
that text is quite explicit yes
because a person who's into pornography
you know they're not just admiring the
beauty of the woman that they're looking
at they're actually thinking about
you know having a more an immoral
relationship with that woman
and so you know however we need to be
careful that a wife doesn't say to her
husband i saw the way you looked at that
woman yes you know because because
something of the heart cannot be judged
yes but if it if it's actually if the
person is actually viewing pornography
and it's proved that they're viewing
pornography or it's proved that they
committed adultery
then there are grounds i believe for
divorce yes ellen white has some
interesting statements about the divorce
this one is an adventist home page 344.
a woman may be legally divorced from her
husband by the laws of the land
and yet not divorced in the sight of god
and according to the higher law
there is only one sin
which is adultery
which can place the husband or wife in a
position where they can be free from the
marriage vow in the sight of god
although the laws of the land may grant
a divorce
yet their husband and wife still in the
bible light according to the laws of god
on the same page
ellen white is writing about a certain
sister i saw that sister blank
as yet has no right to marry another man
but if she or any other woman should
obtain a divorce legally on the ground
that her husband was guilty of adultery
then she is free to be married to whom
she chooses
and then you have this categorical
statement
page 341 of adventist home nothing but
the violation of the marriage bed
can either break or null the marriage
vow
so those statements are pretty explicit
uh i believe
regarding the only valid reason for
divorce yes uh and i think very very
important in in new york state
um i recall
it's fairly easy to get a divorce and of
course that's what the bible is in vain
against
i had a
member
she's passed now
she came to me and she brought me a
piece of paper and she said pastor what
is this
and i said you're divorced
and
her husband had gotten a divorce from
her without her knowledge
he was still living in the house they
were still
uh husband and wife in all of that that
enjoined
uh she was cooking cleaning doing all of
those things but he had he had divorced
her he had taken all her name off all of
the the real estate deeds and everything
he had really separated himself from her
legally but was still living living in
the house and she was unaware uh well
of that and and in new york at that time
that's what you could you could do
and so this just throwing away of
marriages throwing away a vows throwing
away of of of other individuals is what
the bible is conveying against uh it
shouldn't be easy
to to get a divorce it shouldn't be easy
to walk away from somebody that you've
pledged your love and life to that
should be a difficult thing right um and
and uh
of course today we make it so easy to
just you're tired of this one or you're
going to someone else yeah that's a very
good text and ellen white's quotes are
very very in matthew 19 you know you
have the words of jesus regarding this
matter
which are in harmony with the comments
that i read from hill and white
there's this issue of a divorce that the
pharisees brought to jesus
it says in verse 3 the pharisees also
came to him testing him and saying to
him is it lawful for a man to divorce
his wife for just any reason
and then jesus answered and he answered
and said to them have you not read that
he who made them at the beginning made
them male and female and said for this
reason shall a man leave his father and
mother and be joined to his wife and the
two shall become one flesh
so then they are no longer two but one
flesh
therefore what god has joined together
let not man separate
and so then they say well moses said we
could get divorced for any reason
and jesus then goes on to say well it
was it was not so at the beginning yeah
and then in verse 9 jesus says and i say
to you whoever divorces his wife except
for sexual immorality
and that's pretty broad sexual
immorality it would include pornography
and marries another commits adultery and
whoever marries her who is divorced
commits adultery that's one of the hard
sayings of jesus yes yes yes yes there
are some things that he said that are
hard
yet
heaven has given us these principles for
our happiness and for our good amen not
because god wants to uh cut you off of
anything that you want but he wants you
to grow and to to
you know to discipline ourselves we we
are so undisciplined um
i think
it's around 60 of marriages and in
divorce now and in the christian
community it's only slightly lower than
that so
whatever feels good whatever we want to
do whatever occurs to us at the moment
that's tends to be where we go and the
bible puts
guard rails on our lives for our
betterment for our encouragement for our
safety um
well i'll stop there i was thinking
about saying something but i'll just uh
hold on i'll hold on there but i think
we've we've we've answered yafit's
question because it's it's important
that that christians regulate and and
orient their lives to follow the word of
god now how do we deal with the other
question that he asks
concerning an unbelieving spouse
that leaves
does that allow the wife to be free to
marry again it does not you know and and
i didn't write it down but there is
counsel in the spirit of prophecy uh uh
perhaps you have it um
that that lets us know that just because
the other person uh
leaves does not free you to
go on and marry someone else yeah and uh
you know um it's interesting that this
particular verse that is
in the question in first corinthians
chapter 7 and verse 15
it says but if the unbeliever departs
let him depart
a brother or sister is not under bondage
in such cases
but god has called us to peace now
the question is what does that mean when
it says the brother or sister is not
under bondage in such cases and most
likely what it means is that they're not
obligated to stay with that person
it's not directly addressing
remarriage uh when a non-believer leaves
right that's not the language that's
used in the text no no it's it's it's uh
more a
you don't have to
force the person to stay with you you
don't have to go groveling after the
person if they want to go if they're not
pleased to stay with you then
they can separate sure but that does not
free everybody from obligation well
let's just pick up our likes and go on
right um uh no the the the
taking vows as you know pastor before
the lord is a serious thing
and and that's why when we we do
marriage ceremonies you've done them
i've done them we say that it ought not
be entered into wantonly or lightly
because you're taking serious vows and
you're calling on god to recognize and
ratify
what you're doing right so you don't get
to just toss that off because you're
tired of the situation or even because
the other person is tired of the
situation so you you can't force them to
stay you can't force them to stay in the
house but the the marriage
vow is a little different and doesn't
dissolve so easily it is a covenant yes
we call it the marriage covenant and you
know
god made a covenant with israel and
israel played the harlot all the time
yes and yet god kept on
pursuing israel but it came to the point
where
there was no return and that was
estonian of stephen of course yes okay
now here we have another question
which is very interesting
what is your view on the timing of the
edges of the sabbath
according to leviticus 23 32 from the
evening until the evening
and then this is the question directly
related to that text
having in mind the different time zones
and also long day
short time periods how can we all be
certain of the time when the sabbath
begins
especially the days when it's past 6 pm
but the sun has not yet set and vice
versa
what's the problem for a defined zone to
use 6 p.m to avoid all these
discrepancies in other words just set 6
pm don't let the sun dictate when you
start keeping this habit but just put an
arbitrary
hour of 6 pm so how do we respond to
this yes there was a time
back in the history of our church when
the brethren fell upon 6 pm originally
6 p.m has got to be it but then they
realize it's evening till evening so
that means sunset to sunset now if
you're fortunate enough to to be in
panama the sun sets about 6 30 all year
round
they don't change times because it's
always about 6 30 plus or minus 10 or 15
minutes always
but sunset to sunset means sunset to
sunset
i think each of us pastor individually
determines what edges of the sabbath are
but the the fact is this
it is it is wrong
mentally and morally to work up until
the edge of the sabbath
there ought to be a respect for the
sanctity of that day amen and there
ought to be preparation for the sanctity
of that day which means working up to
the very edges of the sabbath is in
effect breaking the sabbath and here's
why
the human mind is funny
it will play tricks on you and it is not
always under your control
you're doing something your mind is on
something and you're working right up to
the edge of the sabbath
the human mind doesn't
click on or off just because a minute
has passed i i've had time when times
when
i'm thinking about something or doing
something and that thought will intrude
on my sabbath time you know and i find
it better to
prepare for the sabbath by backing out
of those secular activities early enough
to allow your mind time
to move into a sabbath framework
which is why when we when irma and i do
worship together for sabbath we sing a
bunch of songs before we go into prayer
because it divorces you from the world
and allows you to go into a a closer
relationship music will do that ushers
you into the presence of the lord so you
want to give ample time
however you defined it
ample time for your mind to
divorce itself from the world simmer
down
i'm sorry simmer down
yes
excuse me to simmer down the world
and to to prepare for the sacredness of
the sabbath
you know there is a bible text ca
that uh clearly indicates that we are to
guard the edges of the sabbath remember
in the days of nehemiah when they were
rebuilding the wall yes that the
merchants from tyre were coming and they
were selling their wares yes yes on the
sabbath day very true and in nehemiah
chapter 13 and verse 19
we have the principle of guarding the
edges of the sabbath yes
it says there so it was
at the gates of jerusalem
as it began to be dark before the
sabbath
that i commanded the gates to be shut
and charged that they must not be open
until after the sabbath
so
as it began to be dark
at the gates of jerusalem
so basically that is saying that
it's not
exactly the moment when it's dark yes
but it's the moment when it when the sun
is beginning to set yes that we're
supposed to uh
simmer down
and uh put our mind
in sacred zone yes
in order to keep this happening and to
do those things
excuse me
i think it's important that we we give
respect to
the sacredness of the
of the sabbath i i have a very good
friend who's in charge of a ministry
who's like to play baseball and he's
told this story many times so i don't
feel bad telling it but um
he and his uh his brother would uh
on friday they'd play right up until
the sun was going over the horizon then
on saturday
they would put their baseball uniforms
on under their suit
and they would go and uh
not go inside the the baseball park but
hang outside you know waiting for the
last ray of the sun they'd rip off their
shirt and tie and they got their
baseball uniform and they're ready to go
um that's really
playing games with god which you cannot
do
god knows your mind he knows your heart
amen and the the sabbath goes so much
better when you prepare for it when
you're ready for when you make it the
special day that it ought to be yeah
and you know if people ask the question
what about the polar regions where you
have 20-hour days and 20-hour nights
depending the season of the year
ellen white has this very interesting
statement in volume three of selected
messages page 317
where she answers that
god rested on the seventh day
and set it apart for man to observe in
honor of his creation of the heavens and
the earth in six literal days
he blessed and sanctified and made holy
the day of rest
when men are so careful to search and
dig to see in regard to the precise
period of time
we are to say god made his sabbath for a
round world
and when the seventh day comes to us in
that round world
controlled by the sun that rules the day
it is the time in all countries and
lands to observe the sabbath
in the countries where there is no
sunset for months
and again no sunrise for months the
period of time will be calculated by
records kept
and so
very clearly she says uh several
important things number one the world is
round not flat like some people are
saying
and then she says that where the sun
doesn't set sometimes for 20 hours
uh you know you can you can know by the
records that are kept yes
and uh she also expresses that the world
was created in six literal days yes and
the days are governed by the sun
they're not governed by 6 p.m
they're governed by the sun amen and and
this is the beautiful thing
you know in australia
they start the sabbath many many hours
before we do 17 hours in front but they
keep the sabbath according to when the
sun
sets there for there so so god has made
it actually quite simple
wherever we are
we begin to keep the sabbath at sunset
yes so it's not really rocket science
it's not complicated no it is not and
when there uh a good friend david shin
uh now he's the president of watchdog
hills uh he pastored in fact he just
came from uh pastoring in la alaska and
of course they had six months of like
six months of guard so they took a
24 hour period
at the end of the week on saturday and
the and they call that the sabbath and
uh it works well the thing is you want
you don't want to cheat god right you
want to give god his day and give him
his time and it is for your betterment
that you do so well you know when i had
a date with my wife when we were dating
i always arrived a little early
[Laughter]
spend spend a little extra minutes yeah
you know here i did say okay you know
we'd agreed to meet at 6 00 p.m and let
me see
5 59
6 o'clock
no you want to steal a few extra moments
yes yeah and so we need to guard the
edges of the sabbath to be ready you
know in peace
tranquility
to be able to welcome the lord on his
own and amen well said and well done
well i hope that we have
dealt with your question
this person is from algeria and uh sebas
so uh
thank you for for writing and thank you
for being part of the program
well our time again has slipped into
eternity and we want to encourage you to
write your questions we will get to them
we will answer them keep studying the
word of god for in studying the word of
god there is light there is information
there is inspiration there is knowledge
and uh together as we prepare for the
coming of the lord we shall be fortified
to do his will here on earth as we
prepare for citizenship in the world
that is to come we'll see you again soon
bye bye and god bless
[Music]
you